Let's talk about a recent development
that I find both important and
fascinating. I speak of this apparently
a universal perception that seems to see
Islam and Israel as inextricably linked
to one another. Honestly, wherever I
look, people of every political and
ideological stripe seem to see the two
Islam and Israel as inseparable. More
specifically, they see them through a
rigid eitheror framework. That is, they
see them as mutually exclusive. If one
is good, the other must be bad. If one
is bad, the other must be good.
Interesting logic. No, I bring this up
because as Israel comes under increasing
criticism, so too does the old construct
morph into its antithesis. Consider for
decades the logic was that if Islam is
bad, then Israel must be good. But now,
as criticism of Israel continues to
mount, the logic has inverted. Now, if
Israel is bad, then Islam must be good.
This is, to be blunt, perverse
reasoning. Consider what it implies. The
actions of a tiny Jewish state are
supposed to somehow define the religion
of nearly 2 billion Muslims around the
world. Look, whatever one thinks of
Israel, Islam has historically been and
in many ways continues to be the West's
most persistent adversary. I have
documented this extensively in my books
from sword and scimitar which looks at
the historic Muslim conquests of
christryendom to crucified again which
looks at today's Muslim persecution of
Christians. The facts speak for
themselves. From its very origins in the
7th century Islam emerged as a militant
faith that expanded through violent
conquest primarily against surrounding
Christians. Thus, what we nowadays call
the heart of the Muslim world, that is
the Middle East and North Africa, from
Iraq in the east to Morocco in the west,
was in fact once the heart of the
Christian world. Islam conquered it all
and for centuries thereafter repeatedly
pummeled the last bastion of
Christendom, also known as Europe.
Almost a thousand years after conquering
Christian Spain in the year 7-eleven,
Muslims were surrounding Vienna in 1683.
Indeed, the United States very first war
as a nation, the first Barbar War in
1801 was against Muslims who were
raiding American vessels and enslaving
their sailors. When Thomas Jefferson
asked Barbber's envoy, Juan Abdul
Rahman, why his countrymen were
terrorizing Americans, the ambassador
answered us, Jefferson wrote to Congress
that quote, "It was founded on the laws
of their prophet, that it was written in
their Quran, that it was their right and
duty to make war upon them, non-Muslims,
wherever they could be found, and to
make slaves of all they could." Now,
here's the thing. Israel did not even
exist during any of this time. During
these more than a thousand years of
jihads on Christendom. Therefore,
Israel's 77 years of existence and its
policies, whether one supports or
condemns them, tell us absolutely
nothing about Islam's past or present
relationship with the West. In short,
criticism of Israel does not equate
exoneration of Islam. This is a false
and dangerous dichotomy. To prove this
once and for all, consider the figure of
Heler Bellac, a prominent European
intellectual who lived from between 1870
and 1953. I've often quoted him for his
remarkably insightful views on Islam.
For example, in 1938, a decade before
Israel came into being and when the
Islamic world was at its weakest visav
the West, he wrote, quote, "Millions of
modern people of the white civilization,
that is the civilization of Europe and
America, have forgotten all about Islam.
They have never come in contact with it.
They take for granted that it is
decaying and that anyway it is just a
foreign religion which will not concern
them. It is as a fact the most
formidable and persistent enemy which
our civilization has had and may at any
moment become as large a menace in the
future as it has been in the past. This
is from his book The Great Heresies.
Now, by today's logic and standards, not
least this syllogistic seessaw I just
mentioned between Islam and Israel,
Bellac's strong criticism of Islam would
immediately be taken as ipso facto
support for Israel. Yet, Bellac was
apparently not overly fond of Jews
either. In 1922, he published a book
titled The Jews, which according to many
classify him as an anti-semite. My point
in telling you all this is that
Belellock is proof that just because a
person presents Islam as the West's most
formidable and persistent enemy to use
his own words does not mean that they
are doing so simply to defend Israel as
the charge nowadays goes for the two are
not connected. To reiterate, criticism
of Israel should not morph into an
assumption that Islam which is practiced
by two billion people all around the
world is inherently virtuous. These are
separate issues. The Israeli Palestinian
conflict is localized and tells us very
little about Islam at large. For
example, millions of Muslim migrants are
causing havoc throughout Europe. And
Islamic jihadist organizations with ISIS
being just the tip of the iceberg are
terrorizing infidels throughout Africa,
Asia, and the Middle East, including
Israel itself. So is the existence of
the Jewish state and its policies really
necessary to explain Islamic behavior
and phenomena that is existed since the
dawn of Islam 14 centuries ago? I think
not.